we come to this place
for Magic
it's incredible she's been in so many
memorable movies
we feel like we know but yet she's an
icon she's a movie star
um yeah I think I think let's listen to
Nicole and let's get back in the movie
theaters stories feel perfect and
Powerful because here
they are but if going to the theaters
not quite for you I hate that you have
to see me like
me like I didn't say anything
this could be our little secret
Naomi's got a new thriller good night
mommy streaming on Prime video when I
was a little girl growing up I didn't
think of that as being the dream role
necessarily but
um I I did strike me as something
unusual so when I got to the point of
reading it it was like yeah I imagine it
would be quite
um
a challenge to express oneself with a
mask on for a good portion of the film
you know because when you have these
really strict rules that you have to
play with you you
um you understand them you learn them
and then you work with what you have and
you realize you have to sort of really
double down on the few things that you
have available which are the eyes and of
course in a wider shot you can use your
physicality your hands your the way you
move
um and and you find Freedom within those
restrictions
[Music]
thank you